um so um
this is the real i was at a coffee shop
one time okay good old swansea
and uh i recently just broke up with my
ex-girlfriend at the time i was very sad
and so my housemate took me out for
coffee
right and we were just like you know he
just wanted to talk to me and just you
know keep me
up uplifted you know and i love coffee i
love talking so
this is the perfect combination right
and whilst i was at the coffee shop
dressed in like sweatpants
miserable i some person some what looked
to be like a 15 year old girl i [ __ ] you
not this is by the way i was like i was
like 20.
comes up to me and i know they're coming
to me you know how i know they got a
[ __ ] they have like the
the scout leader scout regiment backpack
from attack on titan
and i i saw i saw them looking at me i
could see this
eye contact not breaking coming up to me
right right
and no joke right she was like can i sit
down and join you for coffee
and and she's like 15. and her friend is
like right there and i'm like what is
happening
uh i think that's kind of inappropriate
like i don't really know you
i really want to do this i mean somebody
being hit on because underage but like
yeah it was just kind of uncomfortable
and just like
what i thought like a picture sure okay
i'm totally fine with doing pictures or
signing anything you want i don't care
about that but
like you would just sit down and start
talking about don't invite yourself to
like
that yeah yeah yeah i don't know it's
weird but they're a kid they didn't know
any better yeah
i mean that's happened to us a few times
i would i would think it's it's
happening at conventions quite a bit
yeah it happens like conventions i
i was pretty beat up at the time and i
was really yeah you wanted to miss me
i was really [ __ ] sad and having like
a girl come up to me just being like hey
can i sit next to you i'm like
i really don't want you right i don't
want to do anything with any women
anymore
it was literally like the day off as
well i was like i was like miserable
yeah well because i think i think about
i think about that and i think you know
she she'll probably look back
at that period of crash and just [ __ ]
cringe yeah because i
can i can like not not i don't know what
i'm saying i'm not saying you're not
saying you should do it i'm not saying
you know i'm justifying her anything
because you shouldn't do that but
i i know that you know when when you're
that young
and you feel like you have a parasocial
relationship you don't you don't know
about this stuff
especially you don't know about you know
the social boundaries and she'll
probably grow up and
she'll look back at that and she'll wake
up in a cold sweat and think
why the [ __ ] did i do i literally you
can approach me anywhere i don't even
even if it's in a [ __ ] toilet i don't
really give a [ __ ] just as long as i'm
not pissing
or i'm eating or drinking yeah please
please don't do it when i'm pissing
while i'm pissing and eating just please
don't like
cause i just want to finish my meal it's
what i look forward to most of the days
where we can have like full privacy so
just like give us that price
not even that i just want to enjoy my
meal you know i just love food so much
i don't have to think about oh [ __ ] i
got to take a picture of my steak's
going cold
yeah but yeah no and this is the stock
image to go along with
this coffee shop i
had i had a you know i told a story
about it
like don't pog at me my dick's out right
now man i stop
i literally pog jumped your dick
i i've mentioned the next story before
but yeah this is the hotel keycard one
where someone gave me that hotel
yeah yeah that [ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy
that i chose to go along with it
um did you know actually this is the
same trio
ludwig
that doesn't look like this is my
girlfriend this is the girlfriend this
is the girlfriend meme with the guy
looking the other way
oh i recognize the guy's face it's the
exact same model
from the girlfriend um so yeah to those
who don't know and don't want to go back
and watch the episode essentially what
happened was is uh
someone uh gave me a piece of paper uh
and they were like this is for you
and on it was there was the hotel key
card and room number
that was signed and they and it was said
uh there was like times where i could go
right and uh there's a person at the
desk next to me who is helping you know
manage the cause when you get the money
you had it to them yeah yeah and they
were like
bro and i'm like do you want it i don't
want it
needless to say i i immediately gave it
to the hotel reception when i was done
signing things yeah
right and they were like why do you have
this and oh my god it's a long story
um and this one's called the bold the
hotel door
the ball with the hotel door so i told
you one story
about how um there was uh one hotel room
where i was on the bottom floor
and we came out and there's the two
girls there yeah midnight
but there was another time where i came
back and this wasn't as creepy it was
just kind of weird
it was like middle of the day like 1pm
was
that an anime convention of course it
was an outfit okay where else would it
be
so um i think i don't know how someone
found out is my room i was
i was pretty careful like i made sure
like i sound so [ __ ] stupid like make
sure no one was following me right
as gant should have yeah yeah this is
why i do it even though it sounds like
it's like a cia in my life i wouldn't
have got it
like i wouldn't have understood until i
got followed back to my room
yeah i just i just don't want people to
know yeah right like you know
um and there was just like
for some reason like one girl who looked
like
in her 30s just like you know how the
door frame is like
like this just sitting like like this in
my door frame like blocking the door
what and i was like well like the door's
here yeah so that's the frame
that's the frame okay and this is the
other frame so they're they're just
there right in front of your door
yeah and i was like hello
and they were like oh i like your videos
and i'm like
i'm like oh no i'm like social skills 10
000.
i was like oh okay i mean awesome like
you want a picture and they were like
yeah sure that'd be awesome
we took a picture and then they just
left and i was like cool i don't have to
say anything yeah
awesome because i was like i didn't know
what was going on i was like why are you
in front of my hotel room door we're on
like the fifth floor yeah
this is like nowhere near the elevator
or anything like this is really far away
i think maybe they wanted i don't know
if they knew me uh obviously they did
when i went but my first thought was
like are they just chilling here because
i get it because sometimes the the lobby
is really crowded and [ __ ] you want to
go to the the alleyway or whatever in
the [ __ ] rooms because they're long
yeah i was just like oh how did you know
this was my door that's really
concerning i wanted to ask her never
found out so through this day i don't
know why she was in front of my door
i don't know what she wanted again this
isn't a very good guy getting hit on
this is just strange ways people
approach me yeah
it sounds like this this sounds like a
lot of strange things that have happened
about you getting stalked just going to
say hit on just we're going to put it
all under the um
this is this is the youtube clickbait
we're going to say hit on in there yeah
this is youtube
this is true and then this is the stock
image that i found for this one
this is